Walt Disney Company Bob Iger thank you
more than just a little excitement
tonight I gather like like many of you I
remember vividly the first time I saw a
Star Wars film but we're here tonight to
celebrate a new Star Wars film and it's
filmmakers the cast everybody associated
with bringing the force awakens to life
but none of this would be possible
without the sheer genius the talent the
guts the vision of one individual who
created perhaps the greatest mythology
of our time and that is George Lucas
George wherever you are thank you George
so ladies and gentlemen the chairman of
Walt Disney Studios Alan horn Alan
now while Alan was joining Disney Cathy
Kennedy was joining Lucasfilm and that
was a stroke of genius on George's part
and a stroke of luck for us than Kathy
Kennedy
ladies and gentlemen the director of the
force awakens
JJ Abrams JJ
while yours Kathy
it's a real privilege to make movies and
everyone involved in the force awakens
knows how lucky we've been to carry
forward this incredible legacy that
George began over 40 years ago it's been
said but it can't be said enough not
nearly enough that none of us would be
here tonight without the miraculous
creation of one man George Lucas from
the bottom of my heart on behalf of
everyone involved in Star Wars The Force
awakens thank you sir
first the great max von sydow
plays and gentlemen max foxy
there's no Andy Serkis miss Gwendolyn
Christie
mr. domhnall gleeson
lupita nyong'o
mr. Anthony Daniels
mr. Peter Mayhew
Peter may hear those drum
mr. Adam driver
mr. Oscar Isaac
mr. John boyega
there's Daisy Ridley
and look it's r2d2
and it's also bb-8
and what if these star wars without
Carrie Fisher
mr. mark hamill
mr. Harrison Ford
so thank you very much for your patience
and we hope you enjoy the film thanks so
much
you
Oh
haha
Oh your shoulder
yeah
and frank kathleen up this way
cast it right up this way
Moody's
Oh
Oh
I don't know
right
better place
everybody attack
Oh